hello and welcome to this video playing
Captain Archer Captain Archer to set
from Star Trek Star Trek right you don't
quite remember and I think it's start
right no who's Archer I don't know yeah
and please tell me in the comments so um
this is my entire London weapon and
white has those weird moves Knight c3
and Group B one plate this is why I
don't quite believe white can count on
something good but it's still obviously
very solid so black also does not have
an action or something so I'll go to a
play let's put this on t7 one day if I
can get some queenside expansion and
maybe like Queen a5 and d5
hmm
he does not want me to play this okay um
[Music]
I'd see it looks a bit strange but I
need to somehow develop the bishop and
connect rooks I might even try to I mean
I might even threaten to take again Luke
a1 a half 93 so this is hanging for real
I believe
so this is to connect drugs my queen
doesn't have many squares but I don't
see 92 maybe mmm 92 worth something
could be something supporter look there
maybe
yeah yeah I also have pawn to c4 which
is good strange it may be but it could
work if I take I can also take I mean
what is wrong with that probably nothing
okay and now going to before
Isis has Ruby 3 also completely did not
look at Ruby 3
[Music]
maybe I should have just played Bishop
26 cover the those squares there I am
that would have been a good move problem
and no d4 is also hanging
well yeah I think at the same is a check
now here's something that would be three
I might take Depot I mean it's AB it's a
big central pawn mmm that's not very
ammonius I can play Bishop f5 and
disposition and see what you done I just
have to put what is that let's check but
it's okay I mean Bishop d3 is looks like
the move
c3 I just take it but it was the house
so he has to play this move can grab it
and now I mean this is the simple move I
can also play whoopsy for it's a bit
more aggressive now let's do it
puts more pressure c3 still doesn't work
I try to double one thing is kind of
important in this structure and general
black gets a Z 76 set up here
the Bishop 1 h2 is completely out of the
play so this is what I like about this
is this kind of setup here in the
beginning the bishop on f4 sucks
Kane's take this once more
stuff him to move his pieces I just
recognize if he plays rook t2 I can
actually take on c2 anyway because
there's made only one that's a funny
text egg okay yeah I can just take b2
one would be three Queen takes D form mm
I wonder I cannot just you can just take
care of course cool can just take care
of course
okay so do I have an absolute killer
move like something that kills him on
the backgrounds I don't think so but
this is this should be good enough
everything is hanging and I just win
this one play him
yeah let's it's a game that shows blacks
opportunities here maybe quite nicely I
don't know maybe he had something when
that Queen was a little bit short of
squares here so this this it doesn't
seem to be so I took it I think
somewhere here Bishop e6 was also coming
into consideration quite clearly this is
a knight a force stronger even I had 40
cups we cannot play b3 sure he cannot
even play b3 and the look is just
hanging of course interesting
and this I had 93 immediately okay
I leveled a nice move I didn't see it
played this which is not bad yeah but
okay this is the killer and we're
telling move
if you takes it I win the exchange and
end a good position on top and the Queen
move
can ya utilize this very nice yeah nope
did not see that okay this is a very
annoying position it's a huge pressure
and yeah why this white is running out
of moves a key point is that this move
doesn't work I can just take s yeah yeah
this is the mate checkmate
and that that means he's running out of
moves
yeah it took me a bit long hey was that
Kay Jenny no and then the piece off
yeah okay guys thanks for watching